the particular relationship I want to
show you is the binder of your theorem
okay I hope a reasonably convinced like
we build this thing by going downwards
didn't win okay to get this we look
above and go further okay
I think you're probably convinced that
there's gotta be relationships along
rows as well okay
and we already saw like a factor of
seven back to the five etc so for
instance let's just have a look at this
fair you're going to need to write this
one with me because otherwise you will
not be able to follow let's look at
these six numbers okay 1 5 10 10 5 1
okay those what the numbers are we've
already introduced some notation to let
us write these in proportion to the
binomial coefficients right and then we
introduce these brackets right so how do
I rewrite this line in binomial notation
I can either do the C so I can do the
bracket sometimes do in brackets that's
okay it's a fifth row right fifth row so
should be 5 0 good then v 1 v 2 v 3 you
get the idea okay good now I'm I'm
suggesting based on this scene is that
there must be some kind of relationship
between these numbers like the numbers
of an individual row look they arrange
themselves into patterns they cannot
just be independent right so what is the
relationship well how do you get from
one number to another okay you can think
about it a couple ways I suppose you
could think about it in terms of adding
you had forward and go across yeah five
yeah 0 et cetera okay but we just looked
in factorial notation because it
suggests that even though it's built by
an addition you know you look at these
various multiplication is in there
hiding ok so what do I multiply by as I
go across here from one to five not hard
x okay five to 10
okay buy one say mama and then well
that's what I hear aha good and then
fifth okay now there's something going
on you know you have the advantage of
knowing that we've done fact
orientations specifically so that we can
understand this so there is a factorial
hiding in here actually there are three
but where are they and how can we make
this a little more obvious okay
five I'm going to write it I'm gonna
write all these same factors just in a
different way I'm gonna write it as 501
501 it's a fraction writing like that
because I see that this is a fraction
right it's the reciprocal okay now I
couldn't write this as two but I'm
looking for a factorial how else can I
write it I think I can write it remember
I'm gonna get fractions in the end right
two times one is a vectorial there's not
a useful one it doesn't match the
pattern I think four on two is a better
way to write it
okay cuz foreign to his students what do
you think I should put in the middle
I think that's three on three
hold on now huh now I said there were
three factorials hiding in there two of
them are obvious but one is hidden
okay and it's kind of hard to see
because what we're looking at right now
you have to multiply by all of these and
then you get to this one but let's just
consider them individually okay v c0
okay by definition right
he's one okay to get to five c1 you take
this but you multiplied by five on one
one times I won't invest again okay now
as you build can you see what's
happening this is going to be five times
four on the top let's just finish one
times two on the bottom right now look
look look look
this does not have two factorials in it
you need another one to make it work I
can't write that this is five factorial
on two factorial because it's not you
just spent half an hour doing factoring
division how can we make it right I've
got to look my - it's all about
multiplication right I need to divide do
you see what I did I'm really this is
flat factorial on three factorial but it
goes on the bottom alright next one over
what is it's gonna be five by 4 by 3 1
by 2 by 3 I'm in the middle now ok how
do I write this thing it's not 5
factorial on 3 factorial I have to
divide by 2 factorial because there's
missing terms up here oh oh look look of
course they're the same it did the same
all right what on not done yet we've got
how do I write it how do I write it in
factorials there's a five factorial on
the top there's a four factorial on the
bottom but what am i compensate with a
one factorial because you're actually is
it tuns one in there all right now one
last one five five now you don't need me
to write this out it's five factorial on
five factorial
isn't it but you've seen enough to know
this actually a third factorial in here
what is it it's zero factorial right of
course it is
so therefore I can you ready this is
just for one road I want this okay this
is where it culminates where does the N
appear have a look at the patent it's
always on the top every time okay now
there are two factorials on the bottom
right what are the two factorials look
here I had three there's a three
factorial into Ventura he is a four I
have a four factorial 1 factorial so at
least you're gonna get an R factorial I
always see that one what's the other one
and that is the binomial theorem